the police were called to Nancy Pelosi's
San Francisco home just before 2 30 in
the morning she was away in Washington
and so it was her 82 year old husband
Paul who confronted the intruder
David de Pepe had entered through this
back door breaking the glass with a
hammer before hitting Mr Pelosi with it
he then tried to tie him up
when the police arrived both men were in
a struggle de Pepe telling them we're
waiting for Nancy
our officers immediately tackled the
suspect disarmed him took him into
custody requested emergency backup and
rendered Medical Aid
Mr Pelosi had been hit in the head with
the hammer multiple times he spent much
of the day in surgery
Nancy Pelosi is the third most senior
politician in America second in line to
the presidency she's among the most
prominent of Democratic party figures
and a key supporter of Joe Biden
the political climate here right now is
tense with the midterm elections just
over a week away the nation is bitterly
dangerously divided and those false
claims of a stolen election well they
linger and they agitate we don't yet
know precisely what the motive was for
this attack but the fact remains it is
the second time in two years that
speaker Pelosi has been the target
finish the proceeding on January the 6th
last year she was evacuated from our
office on Capitol Hill moments before a
mob arrived
the focus for investigators now is the
suspect's online footprint and links if
any to known extremist groups Mark Stone
Sky News in Washington